is one of one piece's greatest
characters he's one of manga's greatest
characters but why well maybe because he
has the most unique and badass sword
fighting style in all of anime or
because of that time where he earned
mihawk's respect with his immense will
power and sense of Honor or the fact
that he was prepared to sacrifice that
honor his dream and even his life for
Luffy but the love for Zorro goes a lot
deeper than just his badass Feats I mean
you gotta love his personality
all jokes aside I've talked about why
Zorro is such an amazing character a lot
on this channel but really you can boil
it down to just these three things that
make him one of manga's greatest
characters as you know Zoro started out
as a strong-willed kid already
determined to become the strongest
swordsman in the world even before ever
meeting quina and their promise to each
other we also know that Zorro is somehow
related to the shimotsuki clan from wano
but ironically grew up in a place called
The shimotsky Village a colony of former
wano citizens in the East blue there he
trained at The Villages Dojo where he
was able to beat anyone with the
exception of the dojo Masters daughter
kuina after the promise to each other
that one of them would become the
strongest swordsman in the world queena
tragically died under mysterious
circumstances now her father tells Zoro
that she tragically fell down the stairs
but it is strongly hinted at that she
might actually have taken her own life
because koena felt that women were
physically inferior to men and thus
could never make up for that difference
no matter what happens this event
cemented zoro's dream even more and he
spent his entire youth training hard
later on he then became a bounty hunter
to pay his bills while he was off
searching for dracul mihawk one day in a
village called shell town he then saved
a little girl from The Marine Captain
sanho mepo who was chasing her with his
wolf later in exchange for not harassing
little girl and for not being labeled a
Criminal by the Marines Zoro then agreed
to be tied to a pole in front of the
Marine headquarters there and not eat
for a whole month a deal that the
Marines never intended to uphold in the
first place so despite being a bit of a
lone wolf type of person Zoro decided to
accept Luffy's offer to join his crew
and everything after that really is
history with countless epic fights and
moments for the future's strongest
Swordsmen in the world but the reason
people love Zoro so much goes a lot
deeper than just badass Feats it's
really the character's personal reality
that makes him resonate with so many
fans and makes him one of the most
popular characters in all of One Piece
sometimes even outranking Luffy himself
in that regard and so as the first of
our three main points what are the
attributes and values that best Define
the straw hats Moss had its swordsman
well first and foremost it's strength
there is no shortage of fans who
speculate that Zorro might be even
stronger than Luffy though it helps that
blades are one of Luffy's weaknesses and
Zara's goal to become the world's
greatest swordsman is a feat that
generally will take immeasurable
strength secondly there is zoro's
discipline because there is no easy path
or shortcut to the type of strength that
Zorro seeks and so while most of the
time the rest of the crew is just
chilling on board of the ship Zorro is
constantly working out lifting the
biggest weights known to men because he
knows that he can only achieve his dream
through diligent training third is honor
despite his ferocious power is morally
pretty upright for instance famously he
refused to let mihawk strike his back
and instead offers his life and takes
his defeat standing upright instead of
turning tail and running away but the
most defining value that you might not
have expected that really define zoro's
character is altruism even though his
entire life is hyper focused on his goal
he is willing to lay down his life for
others and you can even say that his own
dream to become the world's strongest
swordsman is not his alone he also
fights for this dream in honor of
kuina's memory and so our very first
introduction to Zorro exemplifies all of
these core values when Kobe first told
Luffy about the rumors we were
introduced to a terrifying monster a
bloodthirsty superhuman pirate Hunter
but then when we saw him in the stocks
he showed great discipline and honor he
went without food and water for days on
end and he did it for the sake of an
innocent family he did The Honorable
thing in allowing himself to be
imprisoned in exchange for the family's
lives and and when he asks Luffy to feed
him the rice balls that helmeppo smashed
on the ground it shows another honorable
layer to his personality so really the
fact that he was so strongly defined as
a character right from the beginning
shows just how steadfast Zorro truly is
in his convictions to really understand
what makes Zoro such a great character
though we have to go even deeper and
Beyond his values that he holds and into
the themes that he represents as a
character so really what motives does
Zoro portray and what Real Life
Connections does odasensei use in
developing his character and the first
one among these is actually the
religious theme among Swordsmen in one
piece because many significant Swordsmen
in one piece are all connected with one
religion or another for instance Shanks
is connected with Nordic mythology he's
the captain of a Viking ship and his one
arm suggests parallels to the one-armed
Norse deity tier dracul mihawk the
current strongest swordsman in the world
is connected with symbolism from
Christianity or at least Gothic vampire
literature which itself is is linked
directly with Christianity he is
strongly modeled after Spanish
conquistador and his Black Blade yoru
makes his silhouette appear as a giant
Christian cross behind him Zorro however
appears to have connections to Buddhism
now this is mostly evident in his
attacking name such as his moves
crossing of the sixth pass and Ashura a
type of demigod within Buddhism and
Hinduism and both of these religions in
turn were also influenced by a religion
called zoroastrinism from which Zorro
might even derive his name from next we
have the theme that swords themselves
represent in one piece because the
swordsman in one piece seem to follow a
code of honor and as a result the swords
themselves can also be seen as a sign of
respect for example when zaro first
encounters mihawk he jumps at the chance
to fulfill his goal if he defeats the
warlord right here right now then he'll
become automatically the world's
greatest swordsman and so mihawk surely
no stranger to such challenges thinks
that Zorro is just another kid who
thinks that he has what it takes to
survive in the grand line and at this
point he does and respect Zoro and
therefore doesn't even use his normal
sword against him he uses a tiny pocket
knife however one sorrow demonstrates
just how honorable he truly is by
declaring that the scars on the back are
a swordsman's biggest shame mihawk
recognizes Zoro as a worthy rival with
genuine potential and so out of respect
he uses yoru to deal the finishing blow
of the duel for example during zoro's
fight with King we do see what a
dishonorable swordsman looks like King
doesn't follow a similar moral called to
Zoro or mihawk instead he uses tricks
such as hooked swords to try and disarm
his opponent rather than fight a genuine
duel also any honorable swordsman would
of course hit the Subscribe button at
this point in the video next we have the
Bushido now it should really come as no
big surprise that Zoro is influenced by
Samurai we've learned that he has
Heritage in wano and shimotsky Village
in the East blue where Zoro was raised
was founded by samre from wano who fled
after kaido's takeover not only that but
princess Vivi literally calls Zorro Mr
Bushido now in case you don't know
Bushido is another name for the samurai
code or the way of the warrior and
throughout the various periods of
Japanese history the Bushido has kind of
evolved with the times however one good
way to summarize it comes from nitobe
inazo of the Meiji periods he describes
eight Central virtues to the path of the
Swordsmen those were righteousness
courage compassion respect honesty honor
loyalty and self-control and obviously
these are all virtues that Zoro embodies
in an almost idealistic way and really
going by the Bushido I would say that
he's even more a samurai than the
samurai of wano but now I think it's
really time to look at zoro's overall
character Arc and the story and how he
fits into the story of One Piece overall
how does Zoro change throughout the
story and what does that teach us about
his character that makes him so
incredibly lovable oh but uh wait a
second before we can answer that let's
first talk about my friends over at boxu
Big shout out to them because not only
do they have these awesome snack boxes
but they also have been supporting this
Channel throughout this crazy year as
you probably know box is a collection of
the best Japanese snacks and tea
pairings all made here in Japan they
always make sure to select both the best
new and most authentic stuff the very
first box you'll receive is Seasons of
Japan which gives you a little taste of
all of Japan's popular seasonal flavors
after that you will receive a new theme
every single month my favorites this
month were this awesome Sesame cracker
from Kumamoto oda's hometown by the way
and funnily enough these sea urchin
crackers that were really good I think
Box 2 makes a really great gift for the
travel lover or anime lover in your life
or really for anyone who appreciates
good food so if you want to knock out
your holiday shopping early and support
by Channel at the same time use my code
O'Hara for 15 of your first box of
Japanese snack box when you break it
down Zoro really serves two main roles
in the straw hat crew well technically
not named as the first maid he clearly
fits that part perfectly he is and
always has been Luffy's right hand man
and has been there since the beginning
of Luffy's adventure to back up his
Captain as the first mate he is not just
a subordinate to Luffy though instead he
also acts as Luffy's counterbalance
Zorro always steps in as a leader when
Luffy is incapacitated and even holds
the crew together in its time of
greatest turmoil in fact he's made such
a name for himself as a noteworthy
pirate that just like killer he's
considered part of the supernovas
despite not being a captain himself
however officially Zorro's role in the
crew is that of The Swordsman next to
Luffy he is the deadliest and most
powerful member in the entire crew
Whenever there is any battle to be
fought Zorro is the first to volunteer
to cut down the opponent and protect
everyone on Luffy's ship and really it's
no coincidence either that Zorro uses
blades because while Luffy can resist
blunt attacks and even gunfire his
biggest weakness are cutting attacks
however Zorro can go sword to sword with
anyone who could seriously threaten to
cut down his captain now zoro's
character Arc is the story of an
individual over overcoming a single
Central character flaw and now I'm not
talking about him constantly getting
lost that's his other fatal flaw as we
mentioned earlier zaro is a lone wolf
type of character in his quest to become
the world's greatest swordsman he really
tossed aside all friendships and
camaraderie in exchange for an
all-encompassing focus on his goal and
as a result Zara wants to take on
everything by himself think about it
when zaro gets lost from the crew this
actually serves a crucial writing
purpose for Oda it's not just a gag
because often when the crew gets divided
into different groups Zorro ends up on
his own in sabaori indra's Rosa and
juano just to name a few countries Zorro
ends up in isolation from the rest of
the crew going on a solar Adventure
especially in mono this perfectly
captures the Trope of the wandering
Ronin Samurai and while this kind of
gives Zorro this super cool Vibe of I
can do anything on my own it also gets
him into real trouble when he could do
things together with other crewmates so
it's really really nice to see that over
time Zorro's greatest character
development throughout the entire Series
has been overcoming this Lone Wolf
Persona if not completely of course he
has grown so close to his crewmates to
the point where he's even willing to
sacrifice his own dream and life for
their sake and actually want to walk
through the entire story through each
Arc and show you just how incredibly
nice and subtle this character's Arc
truly is when Luffy first meets Zorro
his life is literally on the line his
unwavering sense of Honor has put him in
a dangerous situation at the hands of
someone as dishonorable as hell mepo he
has agreed to go for weeks without food
or water strung up on a cross not
knowing that the spoiled son of ax and
Morgan has no intention whatsoever of
keeping his side of the bargain and so
at first he laughs off Luffy's request
to join his crew and become a pirate
because he is a pirate Hunter after all
but after Luffy saves him from execution
he gains a newfound respect for his new
captain and so at this point agreeing to
join Luffy on his adventures seems like
just as good a path as any after all the
two both have impossibly ambitious
dreams to become the pirate king and the
world's strongest swordsman and if ever
anything happens to Luffy he can just
keep going his own way now this call to
Grand Adventure parallels when Rayleigh
joined Roger he's swayed by the
captain's Charisma and free spirit which
complements his own stoic and individual
nature and really even though Zoro
walked his path alone if he hadn't
joined up with his captain he wouldn't
have survived the next Monumental step
in Zara's character growth is on the
baratier when he goes face to face with
mihawk arguably one of the best moments
in the entire series he's utterly
defeated but the warlord still sees
something important in Zorro even though
he still clearly lacks the power he has
the strength of will to grow and become
stronger and so the exchange between
these two Swordsmen actually foreshadows
many of Zorro's later Feats and his
growth as a character for example mihawk
defeats him with a tiny knife much like
the knife that Zorro uses at the
beginning of wano to escape his captors
Zorro Witnesses mihawk slicing a whole
ship in half a feat that Zorro is more
than capable of after the time Skip and
mihawk even refers to Zoro as a frog in
a well which is kind of similar to the
English saying of a small fish in a big
pond and then later on fisherman Island
Zara would actually use the exact same
sentence to hyozu the overly confident
greatest swordsman of Fishman Islands
later in Ireland Park and loc Town Zorro
comes to respect Luffy much much more
when he confronts arlong he sees just
how far Luffy himself is willing to go
for someone he considers his nakama and
in loketown he sees Luffy's fearlessness
in the face of death and how he's
willing to die if it meant that he's
working towards achieving his dream
again remember these are things that
Zorro values immensely as well on water
7 we really see Zorro step into the role
of the first mate for the very first
time when Luffy and usop fight over the
fate of the going Mary the rest of the
true are devastated Zorro however is the
glue that keeps them all together his
cool-headed stoic demeanor are crucial
in a situation like this when everyone's
emotions are really riled up he occupies
the difficult position and does what
must be done to maintain the sanctity of
the straw hats and Luffy's honor as a
captain he really understands just how
difficult his conflict is for Luffy but
at the same time even as Nami urges for
compassion zaro understands that the
crew must remain loyal to Luffy and Zoro
also refuses to allow Usopp to rejoin
while deflecting with humor and Antics
he'll only allow Luffy to let him board
the ship once again if he issues a
genuine apology for his misdeeds really
without zoro's strength and conviction
the crew may have fractured permanently
here on water 7. in the next Arc for the
bark we get the single most important
Zorro moment in the entire Series so far
nothing happens when the entirety of the
crew is incapacitated Kuma strikes a
bargain with Zorro the warlord will
spare Luffy's life and the rest of the
crew if Zara agrees to take on all the
pain that Luffy suffered during the
battle on top of Zorro's own already
severe strain from fighting ryuma and
oars this is the ultimate instance of
Zoro shouldering Luffy's burdens and
acting as a first mate and moreover
despite being terribly wounded he stands
with pride as he declares that nothing
happened Zorro doesn't do the things
that he does for credit he has complete
satisfaction in knowing that he's done
his duty and the right thing though it's
important to say that in this scene too
it shows Zorro's character flaw of
trying to take on everything by himself
and really it's the same with becoming
the world's greatest swordsman he's not
doing it to gain cloud or recognition in
the world he simply wants to prove his
strength to himself and no one else at
least as far as we know now one thing
that I think people Overlook is that
during the two-year time skip Zorro
demonstrated just how loyal he really is
to Luffy arguably even more than on
Thriller bark in order to become strong
longer and help fight for Luffy's dream
he's sacrificing his own pride and begs
dracul mihawk the person he wants to
take down to take him in as a student
Zorro began as a character with one
single goal he wanted to prove his own
strength but eventually he found that
through dedication and loyalty he could
find an even greater Purpose By fighting
not only for his own goal but for that
of Luffy and all the other straw hats
together as well he has unlocked his
true strength and potential strength
enough to become the world's greatest
swordsman for someone else so this
unbridled power isn't what makes Zoro
such a beloved character it's not just
his badass fights there are plenty of
characters who offer that kind of action
and so the real reason that people love
Zoro so much are his honor his
compassion and his altruism when Luffy
found him Zorro hadn't been crucified as
a test of his own will he was doing it
to save an innocent little girl and even
though Zorro walked a lonely road in
pursuit of his goal he never truly
walked alone his dream was not just his
it was inherited so really Zoro has
never really fought only to prove his
strength to himself but he fought to
prove his strength to kuwina and Luffy
and everyone who's dear to him so
similar to Luffy more than a character
Zoro is meant to portray an ideal that
through discipline loyalty honor we just
don't lift ourselves up but lift up
everyone around us and so the beauty of
zoro's character is that he shows us
that real strength and purpose comes
from unwavering dedication to others and
even then there is still so much more
detail in Nuance within Zara's character
especially for his character Arc with
Luffy I have a whole video breaking it
down in even more detail right here